cela fait maintenant presque huit mois
que ça y est il est installé au canada
cet ancien interprète a travaillé pour
les militaires canadiens en afghanistan
avant de devoir fuir son pays nous
l'avions rencontré l'hiver dernier
quelques jours après son arrivée
aujourd'hui le jeune homme s'épanouit il
travaille dans un magasin et prépare son
permis de conduire se fait des amis
on track qui forking
go
mais impossible de ne pas penser aussi
chaque jour à sa famille restée au pays
et à ses anciens confrères interprète
ils sont encore nombreux à tenter de
quitter l'afghanistan il y à attendre
des nouvelles du canada qui a promis d
aider
si ça il a finalement pu venir ici c'est
grâce au parrainage d'un groupe de
canadiens mais le gouvernement a aussi
mis en place un programme d'immigration
spéciale pour ceux qui comme lui ont
collaboré avec les canadiens en
afghanistan depuis un an quelques quinze
mille demandes ont ainsi été reçus sur
une limite de 18000 mais seulement 7000
personnes sont arrivées à destination
ce major général retraité et de ce qu'il
était dernier avait sommé le
gouvernement d'agir pour évacuer ses
habitants menacés s'il reconnaît les
défis logistiques de cette mission ils
continuent de déplorer les lourdeurs du
processus de demande et un manque de
communication de
le plafonnement du programme comme celui
pour les interprètes préoccupe aussi les
organismes impliqués c'est un risque aux
gens qui vont être laissés à en
afghanistan nous devrions pas avoir des
limites avec ceux qui ont servi avec le
canada leur inquiétude c'est aussi que
l'afghanistan s'efface des mémoires
surtout avec la crise en ukraine
l'attention des gens s'est déplacé nos
tél et bien sûr les ukrainiens mérite
cette attention mais on doit pas oublier
les afghans
le gouvernement canadien répète pour sa
part que son objectif total d'accueillir
40 mille afghans vulnérables est l'un
des plus ambitieux au monde et qu'il
poursuit son engagement ici camille
guiraud à radio canada toronto